alors
coralie et joël farfouille cherche
l'élément le détail qui fera la
différence et les autres c'est parce que
là adacore une rencontre oui il est au
chocolat j'ai trouvé leur ce n'est pas
la première boutique visités par les
deux copines suis là par ailleurs elle
devrait être en poste des jeunes y
choisir entre déjeuner et le podium j'ai
choisi le salon
mais après je retourne au sein du jeu à
13h36 les 14 heures donc afrique en 2016
l'emmène way en 2017 c'est la quatrième
année qu'elle s'organise entre copines
pour imaginer et créer elle-même leur
tenue de carnaval
un investissement au temps en temps
qu'en argent qu'elles ont du mal à
chiffrer malien 70 80 secondes mais non
il n'y a pas tout ça déjà les contrats
les deux ont peu pâle est estimé à douze
écoles de sioux seulement
oui après sur une bombe aux 10 à 20
ouais bon elle a raison alors je vais
faire les calculs
j'évite de faire les calculs mais c'est
une seule fois dans l'année car laval et
bufflonne belle faut faire des jolis
costumes
donc voila mon âme sommes voilà avec
sébastien proulx pas une minute à perdre
la liste de course est encore longue
non monsieur on va le garder
oui mais la façon des pâtes il est semée
sur les moyens changement de l'ue et
d'ambiance nous sommes chez carole entre
les doigts des filles la matière
première se transforme prend vie
tout est parti d'une idée il y a
quelques semaines
une appli on a trouvé ça c'est le cirque
du soleil et voilà celle là elle et ses
oies ou celle là elle est belle donc on
a on a cherché on a
en fait des proto et voilà on a essayé
des gaines de plombier la havane aux
petits modèles g budget entre temps
c'était le tueur de tuyaux d'arrosage
mais ce de goutte à goutte mais ça ça
rendait pas ekoko a trouvé vraiment le
bon tuyau pas ça c'est de la gaine de
electric electric toi donc après ça on
est parti de là on a acheté 100 m lundi
viser voilà sa fille pour 5 juppé tout
ça d'atelier en atelier le soir et le
week-end la tenue imaginé par ses
copines devient une réalité
on n'a pas lâché
pas du tout pour la confection chacune
met la main à la pâte en fonction de sa
sensibilité et de ses compétences
chacun essaye de faire ce pour quoi il
est doué je sais pas trop couper des
tuyaux donc du coup on m'a attribué la
couture est en fait vu que le costume
est un peu argentés on a voulu
effectivement rajouter des touches de
couleurs avec les manettes de paillettes
plus que quelques détails à fignoler et
elles seront fait prête pour le jour j
mais non
[Musique]
du rose du bleu du vert de l'oranje
elles ont prévu de colorer ce dimanche
gras colonies ta vie donne du sens à ta
vie c'est à toi que c'est toi qui
maîtrise son destin le but c'est de
donner de la couleur de la joie du baume
à ta vie jusqu'au bout on a eu encore
des idées à la fin pour accrocher mais
on est quand même satisfait du résultat
mais un invité surprise semble vouloir
jouer les trouble fête
vous êtes confrontés à une difficulté là
le vent le vent on cherche une solution
pour maintenir les coins donc on va
prendre les bandes de feuilles
on va aller fixer avec le shaq a tant à
l'intérieur pour les maintenir l'on sait
pas si ça va rester sur le boulevard
général de gaulle comme ça donc on va
essayer de trouver qui alla chatterton
hockey
le problème est vite résolu
les filles sont prêtes à l'ailé
direction le centre ville de
fort-de-france
[Musique]
tels des reines avec toutes leurs
couleurs elles ont fait honneur à sa
majesté vaval
[Musique]